I'm not gonna read this it's like two  sentences just do it and then we can go  back to your office and use that thing I  got you I'll read it okay all right here  we go  here we go ready yeah hi I'm private  detective Phil Phillips this wasn't a  robbery this was a hit when I was a cop  I used to write a lot of tickets I never  thought I'd be selling them no don't get  it  grab your tickets now for the happy time  murders on Fandango you guys remember  when Fandango used to use those paper  bag puppets oh yeah so offensive they  could have you know at least employed  real puppets instead of drawing a mouth  on a second greatest lunch bag wait a  minute they weren't real all right grab  your ticket on Fandango  and if it doesn't say the happy time  murders you got the wrong ticket oh boy  I guess they got the wrong ticket mind  sets indecent exposure mm-hmm  I didn't get it from Fandango got it  from a cop dodo that makes sense  [Music]